folks it's hard to ignore the energy
crisis happening around the world right
now every time you go to the gas station
to fill up your tank you're reminded of
the ongoing damage to your wallets and
your pocketbooks listen i personally
heard it i've been at gas stations i
hear and i watch people the audible
sighs and the looks on their faces of
shock when they see the tally
i wish i could tell you the biden
administration's failure to fix this is
because they're incompetent they are
incompetent most everything else but the
truth is what's happening right now is
intentional
under my plan
of a cap and trade system
electricity rates would necessarily
skyrocket
because i'm capping greenhouse gases
coal powered plants
you know natural gas you name whatever
the plants were whatever the industry
was they would have to
retrofit their operations that will cost
money they will pass that money on to
consumers look our view is that the rise
in gas prices over the long term makes
an even stronger case for doubling down
our investment and our focus on clean
energy options so that we are not
relying on
the fluctuations and opec
that's their words you know it's not my
words it's their words no one's
disputing the authenticity of that and
remember this gem energy secretary
jennifer granholm laughing off the idea
of increasing u.s oil production
what is the grand home plan to increase
oil production in america
is hilarious wood that i had the magic
wand on this as you know of course uh
oil is a global market
yeah no it's not hilarious that's not
hilarious uh miss grand home it's not
hilarious it's like your job that's what
you do like you have one job energy
secretary
totally not hilarious okay here's the
truth everything we're seeing right now
is exactly what this administration and
the obama administration wanted none of
this is new so let's break down what
they're doing using the left's own words
after months of buying oil from vladimir
putin the biden administration finally
banned oil imports from russia
terrific except their only plan to
replace it is to get rid of fossil fuels
altogether which has been their energy
suicide plan from day one
long term makes an even stronger case
for doubling down our investment and our
focus on clean energy options if we do
more to invest in clean energy more to
invest in other sources of energy the
president's view is that we
are it is a huge advantage to us to be a
leader in the clean energy transition it
should motivate us to accelerate the
transition of clean energy if we do we
can it will mean that no one has to
worry about the price of gas pump in the
future
so i'm a simple guy i was a queen's kid
from new york i'm a simple guy let me
get this straight we're supposed to buy
into the long-term fix of clean energy
as a solution to the energy crisis
brought on by the russian invasion of
ukraine right now but drilling for more
domestic oil and reinstating the
keystone xl pipeline is not a solution
but a solution because it's only a
long-term fix
what is it man
long-term solutions or not
would president biden ever undo his
executive order that stopped the
construction of the keystone xl pipeline
are you suggesting that would solve the
gas prices issue well do you think that
that would maybe affect prices
faster than getting the whole country
off of fossil fuels i actually don't
think it would
listen the gas lighting here is is
astonishing
again do we want a long-term solution or
do we not want a long-term solution
joe biden is also denying now that his
war on fossil fuels ever happened
simply not true that my administration
or policies are holding back domestic
energy production
that's simply not true
here's the same guy joe biden
it's not bizarro joe biden this is the
same guy
campaigning on destroying the domestic
oil industry and his administrations
followed through on it
no more subsidies for fossil fuel
industry no more drilling on federal
lands no more drilling including
offshore no ability for the oil industry
to continue to drill period ends
and if you believe their lies you know
that their anti-oil policies don't exist
well they have to they have to be a
scapegoat so they had to blame it on the
war in ukraine
you can't do much right now
russia's responsible
listen let's sum this up right the left
wants a destructive suicidal unworkable
technologically unfeasible green new
deal so badly they think they can force
you the middle class to literally buy
into it by making you all choose between
paying more for an electric car or
paying five six and seven dollars a
gallon for gas and worse
they're going to keep using the horrific
war waged by russia and ukraine as
political cover for their anti-fossil
fuel agenda but just how far are they
willing to go a little worried about
that
they're willing to buy oil from
venezuela the venezuelan communists and
the death to america iranian muellers
before allowing americans here to drill
our own oil
is it your expectation that the iranian
barrels do come back online if there is
a deal here on the nuclear agreement the
reason for the deal
is a denuclearized iran that's the
reason for the deal if there is a
byproduct of increased supply so be it
here you want me to turn your internal
thermometer up to uh 107. here's the
hypocritical cherry on top here they
insist it's your patriotic duty to foot
the bill
will be cost as well here in the united
states defending freedom is going to
cost it's going to cost us as well in
the united states
republicans and democrats understand
alike understand that republicans and
democrats alike have been clear that we
must do this
so let's sum this all up here oil
companies are super greedy but they're
not taking advantage of a bunch of
permits they can make money on and that
makes sense to you only if you're a
liberal of course the environmental
library wants to shut down the keystone
xl pipeline but they say it would have
no impact on prices yet they want
long-term planning and it's terrific if
it's windmills and solar but if it's
petroleum that won't work hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else